these workers in western France are
protesting against the closure of a
coal-fired power station and here
employees at a car factory are worried
about their jobs after the automaker
announced it was moving production
abroad the European globalization
adjustment fund was established over a
decade ago to support people who've lost
jobs due to shifts in global trade
patterns since 2007 150,000 redundant
workers have been helped by the fund to
retrain and find work the fund can be
used for vocational training provides
subsidies to create new businesses or
offer incentives to employers who take
on workers following redundancy save
them all you know I say Vanya you don't
have enough Booker will prove it
possible in the personal rehabilitation
elite having a cute Avenue it giveth
homeopathy possible in a shed lump or
two on the back there was that
experience MEP s also want workers who
lose jobs in smaller firms to be able to
benefit from the fund but that not all
pool has a full did have a youth kiss
only saw sleep or the Keystone
technologic set idea the mutational
technology in Ontario blue sector
industry l-o-l oh the hexoren Lee Tawes
issue of you're not I'm under the new
plans requests for support from the firm
would become simpler from with less red
tape and the budget would be increased
[Music]